you look stunning I love the short hair
I do yeah it's very sexy yeah that's a
big change when your hair ever been this
short no oh my god and it was a buzz I
mean now it's like long now I'm like wow
look how long my hair was this for a
part or were you in the military for a
while we didn't know about no no but it
was for a movie it was for this film I
did that SIA the singers are yes yes she
wrote and directed a musical that's
amazing and of course she was like will
you shave your head I was like yep and I
did then and so are you getting used to
this because I'm getting used to I'm
actually I'm now I'm starting to like
wish for an inch longer so I can start
to do more things with X I'm getting a
little yeah you know I'm you know very
female so I like to do lots of different
things with me I noticed yes you were
yeah it is about but I but I I love how
easy it is I do right I'm curious are
you getting recognized less because it
is such a different look I you know I
wish but I don't like I honestly thought
that that would be one of the great like
I'm gonna shave my head nobody's gonna
like ever I can get through anything and
nobody's gonna recognize me and it's not
that way and I and I realize like years
ago I was in New Orleans I was shooting
a movie in New Orleans and it was Mardi
Gras and I was so excited cuz I was like
oh I'm just I'm just gonna like put on a
crazy mask and there's some you know a
black hair and we're gonna ride our
bikes and we're gonna get wasted
nobody's gonna know it's right sure and
just be completely anonymous yeah
completely anonymous and like do Mardi
Gras the way everyone should do Mardi
Gras and like literally I had lipstick
all over my face I decided to do like a
great garden stay sure yeah and and I'm
I'm biking through I've got a drink in
one hand I'm biking through this I'm
with my friend of like this
I hit one bar and it was like
I guess that did not just so what do you
think it is it gives you away well there
was a woman who came up to me at another
bar and she said honey honey we all know
it's you and I was like how do you know
I wish you could see what I look like
does that look so different
I got crazy and and she goes honey your
mouth gives you away and I realize okay
fine I guess I can't get away from you
no I have to like you know where the the
you know what the masks give to we're
like the best you have to wear a
surgical mask yeah yeah exactly I just
walk around like that
I just want anyone people recognize you
if you're wearing a hat or anything they
almost act like you were trying to get
away with something you know I was in
Rhode Island once and I was just filling
up at a gas station oh just wearing a
baseball cap and this you know the Rhode
Island accents really thick and this
woman like comes out from behind my car
and she goes hi sported yeah yeah like
you know I'm not on the run
you